What would happen to you if a black hole,
the size of a coin suddenly appeared?
Ne You short onset,
you die.
Don't announce it.
It depends.
Is it a black hole with a massive a coin or is it as wide as a coin?
Supposedly us nickel with a massive about five grams magic,
he collapsed into a black hole.
This black hole would have a radius of 10 to power of minus 30 meters.
By comparison,
a hundred anatomy is about 10 to the power of minus 11 meters,
so the black hole compared to an atom is as small as an atom compared to the
sun.
Unimaginably small and a small black hole would also have an unimaginably short
lifetime to decay by hawking radiation.
It would radiate a,
wait,
what little mass?
It has intent,
the power of minus 23 seconds.
It's five grams of last will be converted to 450 terajoules of energy,
which will lead to an explosion roughly three times bigger than the atomic bombs
dropped on Hiroshima and Nagasaki combined.
In this case you die.
You also lose the coin.
If the black hole had the diameter of a common coin,
then it would be considerably more massive.
In fact,
of a black hole with the diameter of a nickel would be slightly more massive
than the earth.
It would have a surface gravity,
a billion,
billion times greater than our planet currently does.
It's tidal forces on you will be so strong that they'd rip your individual cells
apart.
The black hole would consume you before you even realized what's happening.
Although the laws of gravity are still the same,
the phenomenon of gravity that you'd experience would be very different around
such dense objects.
The range of the gravitational attraction extends over the entire observable
universe.
With gravity getting weaker.
The farther away you are from something on earth right now,
your head and your toes are approximately the same distance from the center of
our planet,
but if you stood on a nickel size black hole,
your feet would be hundreds of times closer to the center and the gravitational
force would be tens of thousands of times as large as the force on your head and
wrap you into a billion pieces,
but the black hole wouldn't stop with just you.
The black hole is now a dominant gravitational piece of the Earth Moon black
hole of death system.
You might think that the black hole would sink towards the center of the planet
and consume it from the inside out.
In fact,
the earth also moves up onto the black hole and begins to bop around as if it
were orbiting the black hole or while having swaves of mass eaten with each
pass,
which is much more creepy.
As the earth is eaten up from the inside,
it collapses into a scattered disc of hot rock surrounding the back hold in a
title bit.
The black holes slowly doubles its mass by the time it's done.
Feeding the moon's orbit is now highly elliptical.
The effects on the solar system are awesome in the biblical sense of awesome,
which means terrifying tidal forces from the black hole would probably disrupt
the narrow earth asteroids.
Maybe even parts of the asteroid belt sending rocks could reading through the
solar system bombardment and impacts may become common pays for the next few
million years.
The planets are slightly perturbed but stay approximately in the same orbit.
The black hole we used to call earth will now continue on orbiting the sun in
the ass place.
In this case you will say die.
Yeah.
This bonus video was made possible by your contributions on Patrion.
Thank you so much for your support.
The topic is based on a question on the ask science subreddit and the glory is
sponsored by Mack happen who also worked with us on this video.
Check out his blog or clunks and coffee for more awesome stuff like this.
If you want to discuss the video,
we have our own sub reddit now to learn more about black holes or equally
interesting neutron stars.
Click here.